encarnó un cambio de época para la
quinta república varias veces cada stand
fue reconocido por haber dirigido la
modernización de la sociedad francesa
la estación
sé que hoy marca una nueva era para la
política francesa la del
rejuvenecimiento y el cambio para
francia
conocido por los franceses como vice por
sus iniciales en francés el presidente
emprendió rápidamente una serie de
cambios radicales como la reforma de la
mayoría de edad legal que pasó de los 21
a los 18 años pero quizás lo que más lo
destaca como un líder vanguardista fue
su labor en pro de la emancipación de la
mujer valerie hizo que el dinero pagado
por la píldora anticonceptiva fuera
reembolsable por el sistema de la
seguridad social también impulsó la
legalización del aborto su ministra de
salud simón beige se encargó de luchar
por la defensa de la ley que fue
finalmente adoptada el 17 de enero de
1975 después de una amarga lucha
parlamentaria además fue bajo su mandato
que se aprobó la ley que introdujo la
nación de consentimiento mutuo en el
divorcio anterior
las solicitudes debían basarse en una
falta cometida por uno de los dos
cónyuges sin embargo el presidente
moderno de francia no se atrevió a tocar
la pena de muerte aunque declaró su
profunda aversión hacia la pena capital